[Music]
dear BuzzFeed when I was four I just
thought I was like any other boy as I
grew a little older I started realizing
I was different for a while I believed
that I was just a late developer by the
time I realized this wasn't going to
happen I was seven or eight at this age
I did everything I could to fit in and
be seen as one of the boys I were all
boys clothes was happy when people use
male pronouns for me went out in public
and I got my hair cut short a
combination of secondary school age 11
and puberty forced me into thinking I
had to accept the way I was physically
and I tried to fit in as female during
my early teens I could never find
clothes I liked how uncomfortable on
anything I wore and disliked my hair
being long when I was 16 I watched a
documentary on channel 4 about a trans
guy the way he was feeling and how he
had felt flicked a switch and I suddenly
had a name for how I was feeling and
realized that I could actually live as
who I felt I was between my first and
second year at college I came out as
transgender and went back as Jamie for
my a-levels I told my mum first who in
turn told my dad and my brother I then
told my group of friends and finally my
girlfriend who was my best friend at the
time I'm so grateful that they were all
amazingly supportive and over time this
increased as they understood more and
more my mum and I went to speak to my GP
about being referred to a gender
identity clinic so that I could pursue
hormones and eventually surgery the day
I started testosterone was incredibly
exciting my dad picked up my
prescription for me and it was sitting
waiting for me when I got home from
college
so home ensure this as the weeks and
months went by I noticed more and more
changes voice drop in the last month my
muscles are more defined and they are
bigger it's my voice
it's breaking as well I was all that
peach fuzz being
all these changes made me feel so much
more comfortable myself and as grateful
and happy as I was to build hormones I
knew I needed top surgery six months
later I had the surgery the recovery was
uncomfortable and frustrating
it took a couple months for me to start
properly seeing the full effects and
feel the benefits of having a flat chest
[Music]
the only thing that's changing this much
scars are continuing to fade I'm really
happy with whether
we seem to just keep getting lighter
which is pretty awesome now a little
over three years later I still feel
grateful for my chest all the time
the positive impact that is out of my
life is indescribable and that stage in
my life now where I feel content and so
much more comfortable with myself and
with my body my self-esteem and
confidence has increased massively and I
feel a sense of freedom and acceptance
with who I am now something that made
everything easier in the beginning was
having a support network I was
incredibly fortunate to have strong
support from my friends and family if I
were to advise anyone who is just
starting out or about to start their
transition I would say that patience
will be your best friend support is
crucial from wherever you can get it and
concentrate on the little things and
what you can change now
this is a hard process that at times
will feel impossible and impossibly so
but you will get there one day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]